[Musique]
là-dessus la lie à détroit entre tampon
et saint joseph qui fait environ une
trentaine de kilomètres une partie est
entretenu par une brigade une partie par
la brigade trottoirs saint joseph où au
moins me travail c'est une route
dangereuse sinueuse particulière son
relief sa végétation autour ses
anecdotes des vestiges autour
[Musique]
en passant total est de l'avis que doit
fait des travaux sur site en voyage donc
plusieurs aménagements l'été fait comme
ça depuis cinq six ans
[Musique]
à
après c'est vrai quand il pleut
les apu visant les impressionnants même
quand la pluie tombe
[Musique]
mais sinon c'est une route agréable très
fréquenté
[Musique]
là à l'endroit où il est aujourd'hui là
en 2009 il ya un événement particulier
c'est moi qui est arrivé en premier sur
les lieux
et s'il n'y avait pas un homme je
n'aurais pas pu parler aujourd'hui et la
route pour vous dire elle est restée
fermée pendant neuf mois
il reçoit un appel de la mairie à 2
heures du matin et qui dit roy rosa
c'est l'adhésion de mes passes puis
rougerie débute et riant parc arrivé 6e
les demies voix devant moi un bond en
avant au travers de ces bombes m'arrête
et me regarde mais voilà un gros
effondrements là au moins aller plus de
1000 m 2
la partie en aval de la chaussée
impressionnant mais parce que la malaria
soir mais ne verra pas
[Musique]
qui